the gal who's playing Snow White or as I
now call her sand taupe sand beige
snow the snow white who is upending all
the traditions of Snow White she's she's
got another another viral hit
so she's out there protesting with sag
after the actors Union and she's saying
you know I need a better contract why do
I need a better contract because I'm
working this terrible hard job and I'm
not being paid enough for it yeah I'm
the star in the new Snow White movie but
if I've got to go out there and wear
that stupid dress I gotta go wear that
dress all day long I gotta be on set
and I gotta dress up and play pretend
and I have to be a little girl's dream
and I need to make believe for my job
and I need to receive adulation and
praise and lots of money
if I have to do that damn it I'm gonna
make even more money
boy my life is so hard
a person with that attitude is incapable
of happiness
Neil deGrasse Tyson misinterprets the
meaning of the phrase Pursuit of
Happiness that gal should she should
just give it up if that's going to be
her attitude she will never achieve
happiness
some people
can be perfectly happy in even the worst
of circumstances and other people
can not be happy even in the best think
about what she's saying she's not saying
I got to go you know to the coal mines
all day long
she has what is considered the most
glamorous fun silly light job in the
world she's not only in entertainment
she's an actress she's not only an
actress she's a successful actress
she's not only a successful actress
she's playing a Disney princess
the most famous one of all
and she's complaining about it
we all do this from time to time even
even I do it or we just I'm just so um
so frustrated I'm really angry ah my job
is hard
you need a gut check you need to that
take that as a as a warning because this
woman every time she opens her mouth she
says something more offensive than the
last time
but we all fall into that sometimes oh I
gotta take my kids to the park today I
hate
living this wonderful dream and spending
time with my precious children I oh I've
got to go do my job that pays me well
and is generally Pleasant I like my
co-workers and ah man I hate having to
do that I don't fall into that's very
easy people can complain about anything
especially on movie sets that's one of
the weird things about movies that's
people complain all the time and so no
surprise that sag after is whining about
it do not be
like that woman right now text Knowles
to 98 98 98 we are days away from the
Durbin Accords the greatest threat the
US Dollars Global dominance in the past
80 years on August 22nd brics Nations
Brazil Russia India China and South
Africa are expected to announce the
launch of a new international super
currency fully backed by gold or other
Commodities this is part of their
long-term plan to supplant the U.S and
the dollar as cornerstones of the Global
Financial system you can protect your
IRA or 401K from The Fallout from this
Landmark Announcement by diversifying
with gold from Birch gold historically
gold has been a safe haven in times of
high uncertainty which is right now when
currencies fail gold is a safe haven how
much more time does the Dollar have
protect your savings with gold Birch
gold has an A plus rating With Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers text Knowles Canada wlas to 98
98.98 get your free info kit on gold if
a central bank digital currency becomes
a reality it will be nice to have some
gold to depend upon text Knowles Canada
w-l-e-s to 98 98
98. hi Michael I hope you're doing well
I wanted to criticize your Coke and New
Coke analogy of Trump versus DeSantis
provide a more suitable analogy and then
get your thoughts on it sticking with a
soda analogy I think Trump is like going
through the drive through a McDonald's
ordering a Coke but actually getting a
Sprite in 2016 I was very enthusiastic
about his promises of building a much
needed border wall making Mexico pay for
it and draining the swamp unfortunately
he failed to do all three of those
things he was only able to build part of
a wall and we paid for it he did not
dream the swamp by any means in fact he
elevated the biggest swamp monster of
them all Dr fauci into power and allowed
us to stay locked down much past the two
weeks to slow the spread the biggest
quality about Trump's presidency is the
Supreme Court Justices but that wasn't
really anything he personally did any
Republican could have filled those seats
so I'm happy to get the soda at least
but I didn't get what I wanted with the
Santas he's actually distinguishing
himself by making the promise to
actually get the koku ordered and the
fact that he has a really good track
record in Florida supports that what do
you think of this thanks again
and God bless I disagree with the
analysis on the candidates somewhat it's
clear you're you support DeSantis and so
what happens is when one is actively
supporting a candidate in a race one
looks at the rest of the field and
uh highlights and exaggerates perhaps
even the defects of those candidates and
dismisses or minimizes the the great
achievements clearest example I think is
yeah okay he got Roe v Wade overruled
but you know whatever it's just because
he picked judge anyone would have picked
those judges I don't think anyone would
have picked those judges
I think that George W bush nominated
Harriet Myers for the Supreme Court okay
I think that George H.W bush nominated
David Suiter for the Supreme Court I
think even Ronald Reagan nominated uh
Sandra Day O'Connor for the Supreme
Court who was kind of a squish in a lib
I think that Trump's picks were
particularly good they've got their own
problems too but they were particularly
good especially on this issue
and I think he deserves a lot of credit
for that uh and it's true he failed on
some of his promises and some of it he
didn't quite have enough time some of it
uh you know he flubbed himself uh some
of them I think were debatable I mean
the way that he was rearranging trade
deals with Mexico and especially with
China before the covid nonsense uh I
think he deserves more credit for in
terms of you know
this country will pay us you know
whether it's through tariffs whether
it's through renegotiating trade deals
whether you know these are um fungible
complex economic questions but all of
that to say I think my analogy still
holds up regardless of whether you love
Trump or hate Trump I have made clear
I have no intention of endorsing a
candidate in a primary I like these guys
I have interacted personally with all of
the top candidates in the race I love
Trump he's the best president in my
lifetime I think Ron DeSantis is
terrific governor of Florida and Vivek
is a buddy of mine and we go back to
college together so uh and then I'm even
friends with some of the other
candidates in the race and I'm I
I just it's not that I don't have a dog
in this fight I I do in that I have
preferences of this candidate or that
candidate or this quality of this
candidate or whatever and I want the GOP
to win so yeah I'm all about that
but I I think I I've got a little bit of
a remove from the people who are
actively campaigning for Trump actively
campaigning for DeSantis or actively
campaigning for someone else the reason
this holds up is everyone knows who
Trump is
you say well I was deceived in 2016.
okay did you vote for him in 2020.
sounds like you probably did I don't
think you voted for Biden so you knew
you voted for him in 2020 knowing that
he didn't build as much of the wall as
you hoped and he didn't do this and he
didn't do that so we know who he is
we know and a lot of people didn't
expect him to fulfill all the promises
that we got in 2016. some people such as
myself were shocked we got as much as we
did and yes he he pursued some other
policy it like the jailbreak Bill the
crime thing let the criminals out of
prison I thought that was insane but all
in all it was a great presidency
even if you think all in all it wasn't a
great presidency
there's no ambiguity with Trump
we know who this guy is we've known this
guy for 40 years
you I think you're actually proving my
analogy because you're saying Trump
you're saying old Coke is actually not
that good and New Coke actually tastes
better than old Coke
maybe it does I don't know
so says I've never tasted a new Coke but
maybe New Coke does taste better that's
what people said in the blind taste test
but I'm telling you 10 out of 10 times
every single time
that someone takes that blindfold off
even if the new Coke tastes better and
you can make a really good rational
logical argument for why the new coat is
better people are going to want the OG
which is why if DeSantis and he's
starting to do this actually if DeSantis
wants to have any shot at getting the
nomination he's got to run as something
other than the new and improved Donald
Trump because when you put that against
the OG Donald Trump warts and all
people are going to pick the original
boy what a great clip that was now make
sure
make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to my YouTube channel we'll
see you next time